How can you deal with an NP complete problem if you can't avoid it
and a simple algorithm doesn't work.
Well, unless P=NP, you know there's not going to be a polynomial time algorithm for your problem.
Now, that statement actually allows for some loopholes, which we'll investigate
in this unit and the following units.
The first loophole is to try and find intelligent algorithms that allow you to search
through an exponential number of solutions still on exponential time, but so efficiently
that sometimes you actually get a perfect solution.
The second case we'll be looking at is if you accept that your solution is not going to be
the best possible one but maybe within a certain range of the best possible one
if you can then find faster algorithms to solve your problem.
For each of these approaches, we'll be discussing the main ideas.
I'll give you some examples and of course, we'll also be discussing a bit of the theory behind them.